here's LeBron James leading the break
LeBron takes it in and 1 through the hit
on kidd-gilchrist
while just so hard in transition to deal
with him at head of steam plus they have
four other 3-point shooters out there
he's a connector because he comes to a
little bit of everything the rust
perhaps there turned it over LeBron the
locomotive right through and over and
around Batum for the layup injured his
left elbow in a preseason game James he
makes it look so easy
missing Howard on the boards had it
knocked away by Shumpert
good hands by him on Shumpert James with
a head of steam and a Euro step for the
layup right there and back at the old
Charlotte Coliseum remember that spot as
Jeff Green slips the screen great place
to play as he do it justice to his mass
in his size staring down dwayne bacon
the rookie and cooks the bacon crispy
and deep-fried it's been a shot clock
plex moving his feet
bye LeBron Shepard LeBron underneath
LeBron
doing it all inside outside facilitating
well that's just moving a guy out Frank
Kaminsky
oh it's higher than last day and he was
supposed to play six minutes a quarter
but it feels like he played 18 he's
played about 16 total so far and Steve
Clifford says he's on a minutes
restriction about 20 to 22 so they're
gonna be careful with him in the third
guys he in the playoffs every year
career season LeBron James knocks down
the jumper and stares at the fans behind
the Charlotte bench great credibility
inside that locker room but plays like
that by Kemba Walker games with the step
back three money cash first round pick
in the NBA
now lottery pick in it again just shows
you it's James
[Applause]
James downhill boy that's a tough shot
fading away off the triple it's not like
a wrong foot layup right that's their
slip Ron fundamentally sound with the
feet inside to love and a nine-point
lead for the Cavaliers a little bit of a
chance here for the Hornets down by 7
James with an education in elevation
[Applause]